them
welcome
welcome in
to
another live exciting edition of market
takes i am dion robon reporter at the
wall street journal this is market takes
it's our live stream we're talking all
things economy all things markets all
things uh that's that are important with
the the economy and the financial future
of the us and really about the globe we
are doing a very special session today
we are talking about the federal
reserve's july meeting just concluded if
you were watching you saw fed chair
jerome powell come out and speak for
about an hour answering questions from
the media we are going to break down the
speech we are going to talk about the
statement from the federal reserve we're
going to talk about the market reaction
and what we expect to see from the
markets coming forward we are going to
get into all that on today's live stream
so thank you so much for tuning in to
market takes again look this is a big
meeting for a number of reasons because
it's going to tell us a lot about what
to expect going forward the fed doesn't
have another meeting until september and
then after that they don't have another
meeting until november so we've got a
couple months to digest what we heard
here today and for the markets to really
start to take their marching orders so
we're going to get into all that was
also important because today was the
first time that we have had a full
federal reserve board of governors in
nine years first time since 2013 that
the board of governors has been fully
filled so the fomc was completely full
they were unanimous in what they decided
today we're going to get into all that
and what it means as we talk through
today so listen what i want to talk
about i want to talk about what was the
rate decision and what was in the
statement what did we see what did we
hear uh what we heard from fed sheriff
cal at the press conference we're going
to get into that what this means going
forward uh we were all looking for the
pivot today we're watching for that
powell pivot
that you know we we thought might come
up i'm going to tell you what we saw
from that and also what we learned from
the market reaction what was the
market's takeaway that was very nuanced
a lot going on here we're going to have
to jump in between markets but i'm going
to walk you through all of that so first
and foremost let's talk about the rate
decision and the statement as you know
if you're watching the internet if
you've been on twitter if you've been
doing anything the federal reserve
raised rates by 75 basis points 0.75
percentage point as we say here at the
wall street journal that is three times
the rate that they normally hike at
three times the rate they've been hiking
at historically over the past 30 years
or so
when they when they start to raise rates
so moving incredibly fast expeditiously
to quote fed chair jerome powell and the
fed uh it's the term that they've chosen
to use about their path going forward
they're hiking rakes expeditiously and
they did so again today look i think
the most important change to the
statement now they release a statement
after they make their rate decision at
two o'clock
eastern time every time there's a fed
meeting the most important changes i
read it was at the very beginning of the
statement
the fed started the statement with
recent indicators of spending and
production have softened now why is that
important let's stop right there real
quick why is that important well look
the fed has been pounding the table fed
share jerome powell has been pounding
the table saying inflation is our only
goal inflation's our number one goal
we've got to get inflation down we've
got to get back to price stability these
prices going up at nine percent is
unacceptable we've gotta we've gotta
take that and that's all we're
concentrated on well that's all you're
concentrating on if that's all you're
worried about why do you start the
statement with recent indicators of
spending and production have softened
recent indicators of spending and
production
have softened as more about the overall
level of the economy
if price stability and the rise of
prices at nine percent which is what we
saw in june is your number one priority
why are you starting talking about
recent indicators of spending and
production if softened that tells us
about the economy that tells us about
the potential for recession that's not
about inflation which you say is your
number one number two and number three
priority so that gives a lot of credence
to some of these expectations that the
fed is going to reverse course next year
which we've seen throughout markets i'm
going to talk to you a little bit a
little bit more about coming up we
didn't get a summary of economic
projections for this meeting the fed
does those every other meetings but fed
chair jerome powell in his press
conference talked a lot about the june
summary of economic projections he said
not much has changed since then and he
said you can look to that as a guide for
what we're thinking right now so
definitely something to keep in mind as
you remember the fed lowered their
growth expectations increased their
inflation expectations but still kept
those a lot lower than where the market
sees things definitely something to
watch there
the biggest thing that's changed since
the fed's last meeting is there are
increased worries about stagflation
that's a word that has gotten in the
lexicon more and more and more and
economists are worried more and more
about it i want to take just a second to
talk about stagflation
um what you get in stagflation is the
labor market weakens as in more
unemployment more people losing their
jobs more layoffs
but inflation keeps rising inflation
stays at a high pace and
that's the most worrisome possibility
because it does it's it's the worst of
all possible worlds you get more folks
out of work so they don't have money to
buy things at the same time prices are
still going up and up and up and that's
become a greater worry as we move
forward away from 2021 and into 2022
because of what's happening overall in
the economy right now consumers have a
lot of money businesses have a lot of
money and when folks have money to keep
buying even as the price goes up they
keep spending well as they keep spending
the price keeps going up so we've
already started to see some signs of
layoffs and we've already started to see
some signs of weakness in the labor
market if that continues we could be in
this stagflationary environment and that
is the worst possible outcome so look
let's get into the press conference and
what fed chair powell said and and the
big takeaways from that the big picture
was that powell and this has been a
consistent theme we've seen from central
banks over the past few months powell
really started to kind of distance
himself from that forward guidance
remember the fed has talked about
forward guidance as one of their main
tools one of the most important things
that's different now from times past
where they say hey this is what we're
going to be doing markets respond and
that's how they're able to tighten up
financial conditions to get the outcomes
that they want well fed chair jerome
powell today in his press conference
really kind of gave it the ol you know
the drake stiff arm like
nah now babe we don't want that
two
to forward guidance said well september
we could see ourselves doing something
similar to what we've done the past
couple months but we might not you know
we we might not we might do something
different we're going to be data
dependent
moving back towards that regime of data
dependence now we've seen this from fed
chair pal today we saw it from european
central bank president christine lagarde
at the at the ecb's last meeting saying
quote we are not offering forward
guidance of any kind that's what
christine lagarde said at the ecb's last
meeting
the fed has really hyped up forward
guidance as a tool in their arsenal and
now they're backtracking away from it as
they want to get more towards data
dependence which again suggests the fed
could be moving towards
next year
moving away from rate hikes and towards
rate cuts which is what we've seen the
market pricing in so that's why you saw
i think some of the reaction that you
saw in markets before the meeting fed
fund futures showing that investors
expecting the fed to raise rates up to
about three and a half percent by the
end of the year uh pricing in a reversal
of that rates back down to two and a
half percent by mid 2023 and and even
further lower into into 2024 but we saw
a continuation of that where
expectations for ratex this year are
moving lower right expectations for rate
cuts are moving higher so the market
took this meeting saying
powell is looking to maybe do a pow
pivot instead of just raising rates
because we've got to get inflation under
control saying okay we'll raise rates to
the end of the year and then next year
we're moving back down now
if you don't get inflation under control
that becomes a problem because again you
move into this potentially
stagflationary environment i want to
read a quote from bryce doty he is the
senior portfolio manager at sid
investments
and he's talking about basically what
determines a recession fed share powell
was asked a number of times during his
press conference do you think we're in a
recession do you agree with the
president president joe biden coming out
saying we're not in a recession
basically looking forward to this uh gdp
number that's going to be released on
thursday uh tomorrow that likely uh
based on if you're reading the tea
leaves here suggests we're going to see
back-to-back quarters of gdp declines
negative gdp growth or gdp contraction
which you know technically signals a
recession but it's not a recession until
the national bureau of economic research
says so so
joe biden president joe biden getting
out and saying uh we're not in a
recession it doesn't matter what the gdp
folks say fed chair powell asked a lot
about that he said no i don't believe
we're in a recession i want to get to
what bryce dodie senior portfolio
manager at sit investment set um
he said quote economists have a
delusional concept of recession the
population of a country knows when it
when the population of a country knows
it's when their standard of living is
declining since april of last year real
wages have turned negative workers are
going backwards as higher costs outpace
wage increases resulting in a net
reduction of what people are able to
afford so even though we've got 3.6
percent on inflation unemployment excuse
me 3.6 unemployment even though we've
got
hundred thousand job four hundred
thousand new jobs added a year people's
standard of living is being eroded right
now wage gains are not keeping up with
overall price increases uh you're seeing
wage gains about five percent and cpi
overall inflation at nine percent that
means people have stan people's standard
of living is going down
that could be a recession according to
bryce dodie i thought that was very
interesting um look the biggest takeaway
from this i thought was the market
reaction to what the fed said and i want
to talk a little bit about that right
now
uh you you saw across the board really a
bullish reaction to this meeting which
you know i thought was very interesting
if we look at the stock market starting
out there the nasdaq stocks across the
board love this the s p 500 finished the
day up 2.62
the nasdaq finished the day up 4.06
percent the dow finished the day up 1.37
all that to say much higher now let's
talk about the nasdaq up four up more
than four points closing the day up more
than four points or more than four
percent way more than four points up
more than four percent that suggests
that those risky tech stocks those tech
stocks that need low rates that don't
necessarily have a plan for
profitability that are really premised
on growth rather than you know how much
money they actually make those took off
and soared today and what that tells you
is again those expectations for
the fed to back off these rate hikes for
them to lower rates and that to be what
happens in the future that's what the
the stock market move today is telling
you and it's backed up
really when you look at the commodity
market when we look at the price of oil
up big today let's check out oil i'm on
wsj.com right now crude oil up 3.3
percent uh on the day
really everything across the board in
the commodity space was up big you also
had copper up big two and a half percent
uh that was big and also when you look
over at the dollar the us dollar index
uh was down today pretty significantly
uh the us dollar index down 0.75 percent
uh for the day
so when you see the dollar declining
when you see stocks rising when you see
commodity prices rising that's a bullish
reaction to this and the reason for the
bullish reaction is markets want low
rates when rates are low it's a lot
easier to borrow these things cost less
commodities and the like and and the
economy really businesses are able to
take off and charge more and keep those
prices high because they're able to just
roll over that debt borrow more and put
more out into the economy
that's right now the thinking in terms
of the market what i don't think the
market is grappling with right now is
these very real stagflationary risks and
that is that that doesn't get inflation
under control and inflation stays high
and they have to reverse course because
the economy starts to turn over and we
get towards a recession
that could be some very bad news across
the board stocks bonds commodities
whatever you're in it probably isn't
going to do well if the us and global
economy tanks in the second half of this
year or in the first half of next year
and again the international monetary
fund the imf warning that they see
recession as a more likely possibility
just yesterday for the global economy
here's the other worry about that
stagflation we are starting to see more
layoffs if i've pointed out to you on a
couple of these live streams before the
challenger job cuts report for june
sewed a 50 increase in layoffs from may
so in june you saw 50 more layoffs than
in may the initial jobless claims
numbers the last report we got was up 51
from march from the level that we were
at in march that's a historically large
increase for just that short amount of
time and again the latest components of
the ism manufacturing and services
reports that's producer purchasing
managers index basically what business
owners are saying the employment
components were both contractionary
we're seeing business owners say yeah
we're instead of hiring workers we're
cutting workers we're getting rid of
people rather than bringing them on even
in this environment where it is
historically a tight labor market where
there are 11 million job openings versus
the number of unemployed people out
there we are seeing more businesses say
we're cutting jobs we're getting rid of
people rather than we're hiring people
and adding to our employment rules
that's a worrisome sign when inflation
is still at nine percent so the market
loved this press conference and this
statement from the fed the fed basically
saying we want to keep our options open
we might start to look towards cutting
rates again next year
implicitly right that's if you read
between the lines fed chairpal didn't
actually say that don't put words in my
mouth i won't put words in yours
but uh that's what the market took from
this meeting and i think it's very
interesting that the market isn't really
worried about the flip side of that
which is inflation doesn't get back
under control and more people start to
lose their jobs so when you look at the
board
i thought it was really interesting the
bond market is always where you want to
look and the bond market had some really
interesting movement you saw as fed
chair jerome powell started the press
conference bond yields started to take
down as in prices went up more people
buying bonds but as he continued you saw
especially at the back end the 30-year
treasury just spike up higher to its
highs of the day and actually finish the
day much higher than it did and that's
the longest term that you have
essentially
longer term yields are factoring in
higher potential inflation maybe higher
prices going forward that's definitely
something to watch out for and you saw
really the biggest increases in treasury
yields coming at that short end meaning
they expect the fed to keep doing what
it's doing but maybe things could start
to change on the long end definitely
something worth keeping an eye out for
so what are we looking for in the coming
days i say watch those bond yields we've
seen the 10-year yield come in about 30
basis points from where it was just five
days ago in just five days it's down 30
basis points that's a significant move
do we see that reverse or do we see it
continue and we may even see an
inversion of the three month 10 year
treasury yield curve which is the best
the fed has pointed out it's the best
and the number one predictor of
recession if we see that that might be
cause for some more worries among folks
in the market
watch commodities copper is dr copper
it's very moved by what happens the
market and the expectations for the
economy had a big day today but a lot of
that i think was based on the dollar
kind of nose diving and that boosting
all commodities you saw copper oil gold
just about everything rise uh today
after that fed meeting and fed speakers
to watch for we have a new boston fed
president susan m collins not to be
confused with the senator susan m
collins new
president of the boston federal reserve
new fed governor lisa cook we have not
heard from her just yet the new vice
chair for supervision michael barr just
sworn in on july 19th we'd like to hear
from him what does he think about the
fed's pace going forward and of course
new fed governor philip jefferson and
vice chair laelle brainard what they
have to say over the next week or so is
going to be very interesting and telling
us what the fed path is going to be
going forward they were unanimous today
in saying let's raise rates 75 basis
points i don't think you'll see that
same unanimous verdict going forward as
things start to get harder as the
questions about raining in inflation
versus a potential recession start to
get a bit more thorny and look that's
going to do it here for us on market
takes i want to thank everybody that
tuned in and watched with us everyone
who joined us on this live stream and if
you're watching this on playback on the
youtube channel thank you for watching
there as well please join us we will be
back again we're taking next week off i
got a big conference i gotta be at in
las vegas very important very serious
business but we we will be back again
with you in august check us out on
youtube on the live stream for market
takes all right i'm dion rabone reporter
at the wall street journal thanks again
for being with us and we'll do it again
soon